alright man what's up man it's bad
Davion again it's my boy Mike back here
stretch straight out man Kim peeled are
y'all still doing it man y'all still
getting it going for real man I like
this man she's always good dog stupid
dog man we had another problem with some
coupling sees dog I'll help you all luck
you know on say higher he should be the
head writer man telling me he'd been
getting the biggest last of the airport
straight up man
he had this one sketch man we're always
talking about the Indian dude
then he with a doctor and whatnot
another dude was cracking a clown on his
man watch this dog I know this is
hard to hear but we need to make some
serious decisions about your mother's
health let's be honest she's getting on
in years
oh okay I see I see
well yo mama so Oh her last name is a
source seriously dough to make it
funnier y'all should have been like like
going like this this food is good your
mother is overweight
[Laughter]
and then the other Duke would be talking
about Amy I don't understand what's
wrong with this room man this woman
staggie is here
it's a damn boost a kit or is your blue
smile a parcel do be smell my parts and
then the doctor be talking about lips
like the doctor should get like a
prescription that's funny
he's really like if you want your mama
to be button you need to put
[Laughter]
you